we do not have the answers to
development and we have to come to it we
have to learn it and you can only learn
it through valuation
in the very beginning of the development
field we taught the poor were ignorant
they have to be educated and through
education they'll become middle-class
consumers that's not true they are not
ignorant they actually know what is
useful for them and because they know
what is useful for them they are not
buying these things that we are
producing an innovation depends on an
evaluation to become an entrepreneurial
activity I see the evaluation as like a
linkage between innovation and
entrepreneurship and we have to develop
a new style of evaluation there's been
many examples of products that are good
products but they don't necessarily work
the way you expect them to we did a
survey of portable solar lighting device
users in Uganda there are several key
attributes that we settled on after
getting the results of the survey charge
time discharge time water resistance
brightness and we brought them back here
to MIT to test them if we want to do
this using actual sunlight so we decided
to do this on the roof we looked at the
ability to charge in cloudy weather we
looked at how bright the lanterns were
we looked at the ability to light up a
large room what we've created is a
comparative rating shark than a decision
maker at USAID or an NGO could use in
order to help inform that procurement
decision it's really important to
evaluate the product as it's actually
used rather than based on just the
design what do you do about experiments
when you don't even know what the
relevant conditions are it's so hard
when you're sitting in a lab place like
MIT from the outside to really
understand what's going on in the field
there are multiple users four-cylinder
and they're not all what you might think
another way that people have used the
lantern is for phone charging and that's
actually a very critical feature for
many people in fact we found that people
might be more interested in the phone
charging than enlightened aspect of the
lantern so that was actually a big
insight and helps us kind of reflect
that what we think a product might do
what our desire for development is
actually be reflected and how people use
a particular product the preference of
having light may be less important than
preference of having connections the
goal of our study was building a
comparative rating methodology that can
really affect I'm a multitude of
different products that are designed for
the development role I think that the
big challenge for us is to get a lot
more voices into the process using some
innovations and crowdsourcing if we can
make evaluation better and clearer more
thorough and available to the whole
ecosystem of innovators both here and
throughout the developing world
everybody could win from their weird in
developing the framework that will make
it much easier for buying agencies and
other organizations to do these
valuations so not only improve the
product but improve how the people get
the product well next product evaluation
we are doing water filters and also
water testing kits it's the right moment
with the kind of leadership we have at
USAID and I am just very fortunate to be
part of it
you